you know they gave me a piece of advice
before I came to Hollywood
beware of babies furry animals in the
old character man they'll steal every
scene they're in well I'm going to
traduced you now someone who isn't a
baby a furry animal or an old character
man but whose charm intelligence and
sound knowledge of a business makes
every scene she's in her scene the lady
who won last year's award for the best
performance by an actress in a
supporting role will present the award
tonight to the actor whose performance
in the supporting role was the voters
choice miss Claire Trevor
ladies and gentlemen first of all let me
thank Paul for that wonderful
introduction I hardly recognize myself I
very well remember what it's like to be
a nominee waiting I mean it's almost
unbearable a suspense so you wonderful
candidates I won't keep you waiting any
longer
those nominated for the Best Performance
by a Supporting Actor
ah John Ireland in all the king's men a
Robert raphson production Columbia Dean
Jagger in twelve O'Clock High
20th Century Fox Arthur Kennedy in
champion screenplays cooperation United
Artists Ralph Richardson in the heiress
paramount and James Whitmore in
battleground metro-goldwyn-mayer now
that well remembered envelope the winner
is Dean Jagger for getting so excited in
the
taking our bed from the various
we're very very happy about the
Dean Jagger's a greatly respected member
of our profession
and he's played major roles in Missouri
legend Tobacco Road
we couldn't do that much of that they
suggested that if you had anything to
say if you were lucky enough to get up
here and get one of these wonderful
things you you keep it to 15 seconds I
believe it was I I can think of a lot of
things I'd love to say I couldn't say
him in 15 seconds I would like to say
this because I hear a lot of kidding
about what people say when they get one
of these but you do feel grateful to a
few people that helped you to and I
would like to say to a man by the name
of Darryl zanuck who's given me a couple
pretty wonderful opportunities to Henry
King a fine man and a great director I'm
very grateful I feel emotional as a
dickens about it thank you
congratulations to you being Jagger and
thank you fair trapper